I've come to the end of my week in
Vietnam
and it's been a culinary trip into the
unknown and the unthinkable
my mentor V said one week would not be
enough to master this ku scene and I'm
about to find out if she was right
I'm in Hanoi to cook a dinner for V and
other top tutors I've met this week
mr. rice how I sir oh yeah good to see
how you doing yeah well thank you this
place looks amazing let me show you
around here please hello beautiful
mrs. ducks friend mr. rice has given me
the use of his fine dining restaurant a
success is built on authentic Vietnamese
cooking and so it's a great honor
the rest is beautiful yeah thank you
who designed it I designed myself good
job worryingly for me mr. rice has
invited along 30 discerning diners you
got a huge huge challenge and you know
deny so many people here just waiting
for your cooking and I say about 6-7
people very tough ready in three hours
the restaurant will be full and I need
to quickly get used to these unfamiliar
surroundings wow this is the kitchen yes
everything here tonight's yours yeah gas
burners and Grill completely different
layout of a kitchen I like working with
a gas ring burner ten times more
powerful a lot more instant so on the
fly yet again you
tonight my menu will be drawn on
everything I've learned I'm cooking Pig
seven ways up with a pork and shrimp
fresh spring roll yeah we served at room
temperature be very careful a pig's ear
salad blanched in a nice sort of spicy
broth barbecued pork skewer and it's
drilled over charcoal I'm never going to
go to the sweet and sour pork ribs okay
after that we've got a pig slaughter
curry after that kara nice pork belly
finish with fish sauce half that the
pork noodle broth let's go bye bye my
nose to town menu is a tall order
I start with barbecued pork skewers
inspired by mrs. duck the shoulder of
pork slice thinly it's marinated and
then cooked on charcoal now that doesn't
look anywhere near like mrs. duck's
times like this I wish you'd just give
me the recipe properly
I think it's secretly because she had a
massive crush on me and she had visions
of her and I setting up a restaurant
together next for my pig feast I carried
that I hope will satisfy the Vietnamese
appetite for texture normally we use
trotters at home in the UK we bone them
out and stuff them but these are cooked
on the bone and very gelatinous
October Liberty garlic ginger fish sauce
a little bit of fermented rice wine
vinegar almost like a sort of like spicy
curry the pressure is on and already
I've made my first mistake so this is my
broth remember my singing ordeal down
the river I'm just struggling for that
nice sort of lightly sort of pinkish
color I'm beginning to wish I'd kept
things simple downstairs
hah noise must accomplish foodies have
arrived along with my mentors mrs. duck
and madam V all here to pass judgment on
my efforts please premonition is coming
true I'm having a kitchen nightmare I
know the process on cloudy thro turn of
the gas and by rapidly reducing dampers
and fennel it's contrary here are the
sweets our ribs or for them in the oven
but they don't have ovens here servings
gotta be cooked on top
okay poor trotters broth ribs I think
now he's in control
he ain't control now because there's no
salty no yearling from the kitchen yet
oh [ __ ] you now [ __ ]
bollocks
that'd kill me face alone watch out
these guys on your other way please
everybody everybody spectators by now I
should be serving up but I'm nowhere
near ready skewers please come on please
yeah charcoal that's what gives a color
let's go it's gone 7:30 and her noise
finalists have been waiting to eat for
over half an hour to be here here I run
up to the kitchen and then chicken I
need to eat something then unless you
know a long time
skewers please tell them over turn over
more color please come on here oh yeah
finally my dishes come together it's
nice and clear now I've clarified it
some minced pork because they're quite
to get it nice and to my Hamada mrs.
duck is almost ready to be served
fingers crossed man I'm Dexter
sesame seed and at the last minute I put
together my pig's ear salad don't take
anything until I say don't take anything
to the [ __ ] you finish please okay let's
go please gently gently gently gently no
no no no look no stop
yeah that one goes on there right you
come here stand here one bowl hold the
tray tight yep
and two let's go at last dinner is
served
this has been one of the toughest nights
of my cooking career
[Music]
I think what I want to say is he's very
brave that was a nightmare struggled
across the whole three hours I'd like to
think I've done it justice but I left
myself a little bit short but my ordeal
isn't over yet I need to face my mentors
to find out if I've impressed them how
are you recognize you with no hat on how
are the pictures
damn what a shame
ready to see victory crunchy crispy soft
and silly the pig Trotter is perfect
big fix is the most difficult mint to
cook so it's really really impressive
what do you have done
with that and the colors do that I think
it very difficult to do Braille and
today I think this one is done I can eat
it for no problem madam
finally I want to know what the dawning
of nose-to-tail cooking things up my
efforts my goodness me what happened
that's amazing
before you for you happy severe please
didn't see like the best the real soda
at once cures on the choco on the
channel if it wasn't for you this
shoulder wouldn't have tasted as good as
it did trust me
I'm so glad that you like that one I'm
gonna see it mr. ice as always something
amiss people is very hard to face so but
tonight good and I think he does well he
passes for me one of the most thrilling
seven days I've ever spent in my cooking
career honestly if you want to eat well
get rid of your fridge it forces you to
buy ingredients twice a day and cook in
a completely different way challenging
week yet for me one of the most
inspirational
crispy crunchy chewy soft and silky
right Airport